he was supposed to be concentrating on a
hurricane but all the journalists wanted
to know about was this
we've discussed a lot with the taliban
and that's the question he's been asked
again and again we're nine days away
from the august 31st deadline will you
extend that deadline a sign from
president biden that that immovable date
might not be immovable after all there's
discussions going on among us and the
military about extending
our hope is we will not have to extend
the pictures have been dramatic and
heartbreaking babies born on planes as
families flee some dying as they cling
to jets taking off others trampled to
death outside the airport a massive
logistical and humanitarian nightmare
we are proving that we can move though
thousands of people a day out of kabul
and a lot could still go wrong
but to move out thirty thousand people
in just over a week
that's a great testament to the men and
women on the ground in kabul and armed
services domestically president biden is
being hammered from those who preferred
donald trump this was a complete and
total surrender and an embarrassing
failure
to those who really didn't terrorist
organizations that want to attack the
united states now have an entire country
as a sanctuary from which to do so and
even by his own people polls out here
showing president biden's approval is
down to 50 percent another poll saying
he's dropped eight points on last month
the general consensus among americans
they do approve of the withdrawal just
not the way the president is handling it
26 countries have now agreed to take
refugees in once they leave kabul an
effort to relieve pressure on the
current processing centres which are
reaching capacity before they're brought
to the u.s
i've been in personal contact with the
leaders of many countries including
qatar germany spain italy the uae and
others
they're making vital contributions
for many trapped in kabul with no way
out that seems a long way away
my heart aches for those things those
people you see
those terrified of the taliban are less
interested in sympathy they want action
now and to get out as quickly as they
can phil lavelle al jazeera washington